The first thing I'm going to do is convert to m/s.
If I use these conversion factors, I find that all my units—km, hr, and min—cancel
leaving me with m/s, so the velocity that my plane needs to be moving
if it's going to take off is 69.4 m/s.
So this question is asking for acceleration.
We know initial velocity, final velocity, and the distance we have to accelerate.
Time is not really used in this question, so we use this equation.
Now there's a few ways to solve this. What I'd like to do is first solve for a.
And then plug in everything I know since a is what I'm looking for.
And this is the equation I get so now I can plug in, and I get an answer of 30.1 m/s².
Note that 30 is three times bigger than 10.
And 10 is that special number, which we call g and that's the acceleration of objects in free fall fields.
Another way of phrasing this acceleration of 30 is saying it's equal to 3 g.